in five four three two one
happy happy day this is the holidays
right now so I hope you guys had a great
Thanksgiving hope I don't know when this
is gonna come out so maybe Christmas
hope you guys have a great Christmas too
mainly clay smash what did you do for
Thanksgiving I was gonna have so every
you know you're we get my family now we
get together I was gonna go to San Diego
and then like half of the kids got sick
oh yeah and then no one wanted to meet
up and then everyone was like oh it was
raining remember it was all well you're
you're in NorCal but it was kind of
raining and all that so everyone's like
let's just move let's just check let's
just chill some other time we made up a
lot though like me and my family we
every Bert there's like six nieces and
nephews wait no four here
so and you know everyone's birthdays
we're always meeting up for every
freaking birthday do you like
Thanksgiving food I love it yeah I feel
like everybody's half half on it I feel
like a lot of people just eat
Thanksgiving food because they feel like
they have to that's true you know cuz if
you had an option of doing other foods
besides things like for me I did all
Korean food oh really yeah cuz my mom
was like are you gonna cook Thanksgiving
feels like nah this is what I wanted
yeah like [ __ ] that let's just let's
just have Korean food so we had like a
whole spread of Korean food like we had
a Korean short ribs we're like topshe
all this other stuff and we demolished
all that food but you know what that
sounds good with like American
Thanksgiving food I think once we have a
couple of bites where do you kind of
move on because all really yeah um oh
well you know what I like is okay so
like I don't ever like Turkey from
people yeah I like it from a smokehouse
hmm so if you get smoked turkey or if
you get it delivered
that shit's good smoked ham all that
stuff - it's really good unless there's
someone in the family that can like do
it really well in most cases I never met
anyone that can do it really well
there's a lot of people who cook turkey
really bad like I might be decent but
then I go through a whole process of
like I like su Viet for like you know
like a whole day and then I deep-fry it
at the end so damn it's like it tastes
pretty good
but if I had a choice would I rather
have turkey or chicken I take chicken
all day yeah same here
it just tastes different but smoked
turkey I
smoked turkey so that and then you know
the sides and the mac and cheese and all
that I think it's yeah I don't know you
see up my buddy you see this back in the
day where his parents you still in a
Chinese restaurant they you should take
their Turkey and they sold out on their
cookie turkeys every year is because
they would do turkey Peking Duck style
why what does that taste like tastes
like it tastes like the best like
Chinese flavors smoked piece of ham but
in Turkey form because I love pecking
duck man dude it they do it imagine that
but as a turkey and the flesh turns more
like ham like then then whatever the
process is that how they cook it but it
tastes like a ham like food it's so
[ __ ] like crave that [ __ ] every day
but I'll talk to that [ __ ]
anymore so is duck the same as those
hanging ducks at the Chinese like
barbecue place I know like samu barbecue
you have the hanging duck rows are
picking ducks okay
yeah like the whole process of making a
picking duck is so difficult I think
that's why most people just don't make
it at home don't they have like a
special oven for it and then they torch
it and all that [ __ ] they do all this
crazy stuff like I seen this process
where they'll take this they'll first
think they have to separate the muscle
and the fat from the skin yeah cuz they
need that separation to crisp it up
right but then there's this whole drying
process this aging process paint lacquer
it up they cook it they dry they do this
whole spiel that's why I mean house is
so good how many Chinese parents do we
know that they've ever made Peking duck
at home I've never seen it at home yeah
but right they always they always buy it
out because the process is so damn
annoying yeah
I've been finding out too just watching
people cook and this is this is
interesting because I think a lot of
people wonder how how so many
restaurants in LA open close and I think
like restaurant la food is very
competitive right and I think in most
places to it especially it back in the
day when we were super younger that when
people opened up restaurants it was just
a means to an end so it's like I need to
make money I can make a few dishes I'm
gonna open up a diner yeah that's like
easy food to make but in LA you don't
really have that it's competition out
here you know if you want to open up a
restaurant that food needs to to make a
point and it needs to leave an
impression on you if not you're really
just not going to go there unless it's
like some of those later late-night
spots which everybody just goes eat
super late at night after the
or they're super drunk those will
survive but just like with anything with
cooking and I always find this out
during Thanksgiving is that there's a
lot of people who think they can cook
but a lot of people can't [ __ ] cook
hahaha and it is a terrible terrible
[ __ ] thing makes you say that like
from potlucks or you mean like I've had
food from other people who do
Thanksgiving food oh yeah and it's just
like [ __ ] man like you can't [ __ ]
cook but they gas themselves up so hard
and they invite us over they're like yo
man I'm about to do this whole feast I'm
gonna make this ham I'm gonna do this
turkey this mac and cheese for cheese
mac and cheese and I go there I'm like
yo the food is trash like the people are
better at making things look good than
making food taste good oh yeah that's
true why is that like they don't not a
season right and to me seasoning so
simple yeah you salt [ __ ] yeah man
exactly one of our friends like I'm not
gonna put this [ __ ] on blast
even though god I wish I really could
but I'm learning how to be a better
person but every time this [ __ ]
invites me over right and this person
always gasses themself up to like yo on
Instagram like cooking up this meal and
you know people like also tell her that
yo like oh I wish I had some of that and
I went over this person's house a couple
of times because I wanted to see what
the food tasted like and I eat the food
and they're just they're gassing
themselves up they're like yo how good
is that that's just delicious and I'm
like you did a tablespoon of salt in any
of this [ __ ] well I think I lost tail
soup also this [ __ ] this fancy [ __ ] yeah
and I ate this food multiple times and
it [ __ ] sucks
so now now any of for me I didn't tell
them that I didn't like the food so
every time they cook something they look
at me and be like and I have to go there
and eat that [ __ ] I still go I'll try to
ignore a majority of the time but then
if I it's all dude like [ __ ] why is that
that's so weird cuz there is bland food
but then there's like tasteless food
there's a difference right like bland
could be like oh yeah it's it's clean I
guess or you know what that is - yeah
it's that same concept and I always say
this when it comes to food I'm not
saying like I'm this amazing chef right
but I make decent food right people
just cuz you it's like this example just
cuz you go to college doesn't mean
you're a smart person that's cuz you
pick up a knife and a pot doesn't mean
you're a great cook that's true okay and
it's the same [ __ ] concept yeah so
that's why sometimes when I go to these
restaurants and ate the food and you
know some of this stuff is preference
and other times it's not right and
there's just certain stuff that the
basis aren't [ __ ] covered and when I
when I eat these people's food it's just
the basics aren't covered they look at a
recipe as if it's the Bible for how
something should taste I don't have a
discernible palate for food I see you
know so like when they when they make
something the the recipe said two
teaspoons they don't even taste it they
go two teaspoons and they move on oh so
they're not really checking for
seasoning they don't understand why
things taste a certain way why things
turn out a certain way and they don't
question their food a lot and so there's
just no improvement it's like anything
that we do we have to question it and
see what happens out yeah yeah yeah it's
a skill yeah that's okay that makes
sense I just thought that they grew up
eating [ __ ] at home so they have a very
bad like like a bar like they're like I
mean taste is just like music right like
we eat you listen it's just a sense yeah
so some people you know they grow up
eating really garbage [ __ ] and they have
like different standards yeah and I
don't know like for me I lately what
I've been doing is I've just been
experimenting a lot on animal like broth
or like yeah and then just trying to
take in pure flavours like oh I have a
[ __ ] fish head just boiling at the
house right now what the [ __ ] you make
you fish heads do I'm making some broth
yeah oh yeah yeah because you know I've
been reading some [ __ ] about how
collagen or fish oils and just all this
[ __ ] is really good for you yeah so the
[ __ ] that we would make fun of Casey
like I'm eating all that trash
Casey's different though man this
[ __ ] would eat the toe off of a
duck trash he goes down
but I've been I've been more conscious
about the collagen in the tendons and
things like so over here yeah it's
supposed to be free good for your nails
for your hair for like your joints and
all that and I'm like man I'll just
[ __ ] try it out let me try this stuff
and then so now I'm cooking more for a
purpose and less for flavor yeah so I
mean you could do both I can yeah and
then I'm discovering more things about
flavor though from that there's like I
mean like when I make the broth you know
I taste it first so I'm like oh you know
what I haven't really tasted broth
without salt cuz I'm already putting
[ __ ] in there mm-hmm
so just being able to taste like the
animal by itself you should use like
different things make it taste different
like for example like like a pork
shoulder might be different from like
using pork belly or like you know like
fish head might be different from using
clam or like and I'm like oh [ __ ] and
then you start to mix the two together
and I'm like this is why ramen guys go
so hard with their secret like 20
different things in a broth yeah like
they'll have like pork with [ __ ] and
dashi and they'll have lady tell they
got everything you know Senta and that's
[ __ ] crazy but see I like the way
that you cook though because that makes
sense to me
yeah so when I was doing so I did this
show and it had to do with food and so
basically like there's there's a lot of
chefs that I see that come on and once
again this is not from somebody who's a
professional chef I'm not a professional
chef myself right but I do own food
businesses and they do well right so
there's something to it there's this
thing of like sometimes it goes one way
where people are too textbook and so
there's not a lot of soul in their food
right and you could really taste that
type of [ __ ] when something just tastes
so [ __ ] textbook there's no there's
nothing that's elevating their dish
right or you sometimes you go to the
right side where somebody's not textbook
at all they don't understand basic
techniques and so things just tend to
[ __ ] up right like for example there's
somebody that was cooking and you could
tell the way he was doing plating swipes
like
you swiping a sauce on and layering
things or whatever right but the
foundation of what it makes a good dish
wasn't there for example salt can [ __ ]
you know what I mean my salt no salt
like no see right and things don't make
sense right so they're there picking
apart small things that they like here
and there and they're trying to put it
into a singular dish without thinking of
something being cohesive right so it's
like cool so you did this you know jala
technique and you did this foam that's
cool it's technically there why is it on
this plate what am i tasting you know
and so people don't understand - and
sometimes you have too much powerful
flavors they'll cancel each other out
and it just tastes like nothing
yeah and people don't understand that
concept that's why there's levity in a
dish right there's acid there's fat
there's texture it's just to take you
somewhere right yeah and I think that we
have such a high access for food people
are having trouble with like really
focusing on one thing work on like
foundation and basics - why food tastes
a certain way and then build on top of
that which I this is why I like Japan a
lot because they do apprenticeship and
they work on those foundation basics a
lot you learned how to make an egg for
20 years [ __ ] dude that [ __ ] zero
well he opened up his own really popular
restaurant in Seattle now he's like the
top sushi chef in like in the States
crazy man and this [ __ ] was
making an egg for like ten [ __ ] years
sucked he kept getting bullied I know
you're not the good yet and then he
would just kept doing it over and over
he said that when he finally got he said
you did a good job he busted down crying
Japanese people are very particular
about their [ __ ] but no cd he's super
OCD man and I think that's what I like
about when we went to Japan like yeah
kind of Tate and I saw that ramen dock -
oh yeah yeah it's crazy dog dudes - it
looks crazy man yeah and there's
superstars out there yeah that guy was
[ __ ] ballin the the the big rock
stars rock star dude and then they're
all tatted up and like I have like
themes and they always have like these
big-ass lines this podcast is brought to
you by Skillshare my friends if you have
not heard of Skillshare well let me tell
you about Skillshare Skillshare is all
about lifelong learning I know there's a
lot of people out there
and have hobbies or maybe even some new
entrepreneurial skills that you want to
develop outside of the stuff that you
already know well Skillshare have has
thousands of class on deck for you to
pick and choose from Skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of amazing classes covering dozens of
creative skills you can take classes in
everything from photography and creative
writing to design productivity and a
whole bunch more so whether you're
returning to a long time passion project
challenging yourself to get outside of
your comfort zone or simply exploring
something new Skillshare has classes for
you I am an amateur photographer I'm
getting better at it every day but I
need to know my basics and I want to
learn these things outside I'm just you
know picking up a photography class in a
community college and I want to learn at
my own pace I'm a busy guy so Skillshare
has a huge library for me to pick from
specifically and something that I want
to know which is photography there's
videography skills there's a whole bunch
of stuff but I've been using a
photography and I gotta tell you it's
helped me out a lot
brushed up on my foundations so check it
out join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for free that's right Skillshare is
offering genius bearing listeners two
months of unlimited access to thousands
of classes for free to sign up go to
Skillshare comm slash brain again go to
Skillshare comm slash brain to start
your two months now that Skillshare
dot-com slash brain man I want to go I
want to go Japan just did like a ramen
tour like they have ramen tour guides
that will take you yeah they'll just
take you to every single spot that's
like in things change too like I think
by the time we know what's popular in
the States or outside they already moved
on yeah like you know how Jiro wind
Netflix documentary and all that came
out you know we thought he was poppin
and then my mom was like oh he's old
news man that's crazy she looked at me
like I was lame and outdated
she's like everyone out here yeah dude I
was like no everyone it like his son is
where it's at now like cuz out there the
traditional [ __ ]
is not what they want they want
something fresh everything's evolving
yeah so like for us we want the core
traditional because we can't have that
you know yeah yeah when we go there well
like give me give me the traditional
authentic Japanese stuff and then we get
it but to them they're like we get this
every day that's traditional that's what
my grandma eats when I had um when I was
looking at them making ramen
the main guy that they were focusing on
that fool on his off day eats at least
three bowls yeah yes I [ __ ] crazy all
he eats is Rob using anything else
that's [ __ ] crazy that's so obsessive
and his noodles were so much thicker
yeah any ramen I've ever seen it's even
thicker than skim it mm-hmm and that's
for his regular ramen too he's the same
noodle yeah that's his style
what's cool about ramen though is it's
like very unhappy knees because most
Chinese right originally yeah so it's
very um it's free there's a lot of
freedom there so the food culture in
Japan is like there's a lot of
traditional dishes that they're very
particular about preserving the culture
and making it as like Orthodox as
possible they have that concept right so
in Japanese cooking it's kind of like
it's - I don't know pretentious in a way
where it's like it has to be this way
and if it's not that way then it's not
perfect yeah but ramen is one of those
things where it's not considered
Japanese so there is no traditional
Japanese thing to it so you could do
whatever you want yeah so you can use
whatever broth you can do anything
really so that's why they can go out and
go wild that's why they have so many
different variations of it yeah it's
like the it's like the punk culture of
food in Japan oh really
yeah so like ramen is like the cool like
you can be what I move yeah that's why
those guys are all tattooed up and like
cool and like you know yeah
well that's interesting because I always
have you know it's weird when people
think that um because we do food they I
hate this one word that I'm really
starting to hate and it's because I
think I I I'm at fault for this too is a
authenticity all right so when people
talk about food they go well that's not
authentic
it's not good what is authentic mean and
I really have the assets to people just
because like authenticity in terms of
food and I'm really directing this
towards [ __ ] white people you guys
talk about like authenticity about other
food it's like well this isn't really
authentic it's like well what the [ __ ]
do you know maybe they're just talking
about non commercialized like
whitewashed versions of it and I don't
want people to really think about this
when it comes to food and you say
something like authentic if I had a
group of a hundred Korean people right
and they and obviously they all each
hundred people they had their parents
and I told all hundred people their
parents should make attend junggigo
which is a bean paste fermented soup
right it's a stronger form Penn Jung is
a very strong form of miso it's way more
fermented it smells like [ __ ]
butthole right yeah I've had that
feature it's one of my favorite soups
every single parent that makes that
they're they're ten junggigo will taste
completely different from the other
person cuz everyone's toast smell the
same bacteria so you make this so the
reason why I bring that up is because so
when we're talking about authenticity
what's really authentic right who's to
say Adam all those hundred dishes where
each hundred person made that difference
and they're all Korean or Korean
American who's who's a soybean paste
soup is authentic I don't know exactly
you don't know everybody has different
variations of their food yeah and I
think that what we kind of tell people
that food should only be this way in a
certain way we kind of pigeon-holed
ourselves and we don't allow food to
evolve which I should always evolve you
do not want to eat a lot of the food
that we had a hundred years ago now yeah
I mean all the food in Japan has evolved
so like look at the baked goods in Japan
oh yeah they learned that from the Dutch
that's so dope they learned how to bake
from there and then that's why they call
it pond mmm they call bread pond Oh out
there oh that's right this is a Japanese
[ __ ] award i smoking crazy yeah like
when I mean I grew up here in LA and you
know in Little Tokyo or like torrents
there's Japanese like restaurants right
then there but they're like a time like
capsule like they came in the 70s or 80s
or whatever there's older ones too but
they kind of kept it the way that it was
so when I go to Japan I'm like oh my god
the food has evolved it's so different
but if I go to like a small little town
it's similar to like how they have it
here in Little Tokyo or whatever so then
that that's why there's all these new
restaurants coming in from Japan that
just blows out like the competition here
in the States because we're stuck in a
time capsule yeah they haven't involved
mmm see that kind of makes sense and III
I like fusion food in the sense of like
I like fusion food when you don't know
what the food really is meaning that I
don't like I mean like you take a
burrito and you just throw something in
it and it's considered for you you know
I mean like there's some cotton candy
and a taco in it
taco inside of a burrito tell you this
[ __ ] nasty story after this but like
for example what I mean by that and we
go back to the topic of authenticity and
food like Vietnamese food is a clear
example of fusion right I'm so good
right a bun me is a [ __ ] French bread
with a Vietnamese version of a pate
inside which is also [ __ ] French
these pickled vegetables all this others
the the what's it called
you know the jet the if you get a
combination Bundy you get the that meat
that pink meat inside oh yeah yeah yeah
that's head cheese head cheese is like
French charcuterie you see that in
French charcuterie
that in and of itself is a fusion food
yeah and that is food innovation at its
finest
yeah like pate and everything exactly
but you don't hear people going oh
that's not real Vietnamese food you know
what I'm saying yeah that's true it
doesn't really make sense yeah they even
have the French bread in the curry and
like look this curved yeah oh yeah the
curry that curries from the spices from
India
yeah they and in the breads from France
yeah people even talk about like the the
new I think it was like southern style
pho which is a lot more clear that's
basically a consomme broth yeah and so
there's all this like influence that
happens to food and I think that when
you tell somebody that they can't do
something with food just because it's
not authentic but you went into an issue
I understand when somebody calls
something that it's this and it doesn't
taste like it then you're like okay well
that's not what it is yeah but it's your
rendition of it I understand because I I
don't like food
that sometimes - yeah they're probably
just talking about the whitewashing of
food you know when they make it more
palatable for the anglo-saxons because I
mean it's when it's too ethnic or like
just anything like even when you go to
Japan right you have - all that food
it's not quite authentic like they have
to make it for the population there same
with Vietnam or whatever like cuz
there's Indian food there's Chinese food
there's all that like there's different
kinds of foods in Japan but you have to
make it portable yeah for that
population and I think in America that's
what happened for a long time all of the
food was catered to the mainstream
market which is like if your ethnic yeah
and if you're coming into like a major
city that has a high population of white
people you're probably gonna have to
cater your food to them and also you
don't have the right ingredients like
the when you go out of state now you see
more like of these Chinese restaurants
that are like closer to the ones that we
have out here but if you remember like
back in a day like 30 20 years ago or
whatever like the Chinese restaurants
they still have this like in the Midwest
or whatever but they don't have that
many ingredients that have they have
access to now so they'll use like the
local vegetables and all that but all
their stuff is like it reminds me of
like truckstop pound Express yeah and
I'm like that's what people thought
Chinese food was but they're just trying
to like make do with what they got but
is that inauthentic I don't know I feel
like that's American
yeah that's American Chinese food yeah
which has this has its place because I
[ __ ] love American Chinese food me
too I love that [ __ ] bro yeah like I
don't understand Asians that are like
that's not real wouldn't eat that [ __ ]
I'm like I'll eat it all like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about man - yeah
when you they give you the [ __ ]
wonton crisps with a little sweet and
sour sauce that you dip the [ __ ] the
cream cheese wonton bro yeah the [ __ ]
general tso chicken that [ __ ] ain't
welcome real Chinese food or some [ __ ]
that's just delicious I love I [ __ ]
go down on a beef and broccoli hella
good I'm pretty sure I'm thousands
position that's not
take Chinese for some people like they
identify their their identity with food
too much to the point where like they
find it offensive and I'm like man if it
tastes good [ __ ] it dude I'm hungry
exactly yeah that whole yeah maybe it's
that whole whitewashing of certain
things that people got really offended
by cuz I understand that to a certain
extent yes like we're like we have these
foods that we were made fun of when were
younger but then you just one white chef
that tries to educate other people about
a food that was already ours it kind of
takes the the it's our spirit from our
food like our culture yeah if you use it
whenever you feel like it's okay to use
it yeah I think that's where people get
a little weirded out by it right aside
well hold on a second I used to get
[ __ ] clowned on for that food and now
that you know you have you know George
pickle McPherson just he's over here
just telling people like amen so this is
how you're gonna cook chow mein and this
is how it's gonna be when it's authentic
yeah that's the verbage where it [ __ ]
them up yes like maybe you shouldn't
have said the word authentic said this
is how I learned how to make Chinese
food from blah blah blah blah yeah and
this is this is this is my version of it
cool you know but then when you say
something like authenticity with the
culture who didn't even get to own up to
the donis of it and you get to take
credit for it first yeah that's where
people start to feel a little weird you
know yeah I mean when I hear that stuff
too I'm also like he's probably just
talking to other white people probably
you know I feel like that too
like that one white guy that was doing
remember he got a lot of flack for
[ __ ] uh this is how you make
authentic [ __ ] and all that to me what I
saw was a guy introducing Vietnamese
noodles to his culture not to me to why
people he was talking to other white
people that didn't know what this was
yeah so then I but I also see why
Vietnamese people were like what the
[ __ ] bro like that that's not you didn't
even do it right or whatever you know
and then then it's like oh [ __ ] like
maybe you should have considered that
the whole world's a part of this [ __ ]
but I don't know man this is kind of
weird because you know that guy Ivan
ramen oh yeah he said well yeah he's
[ __ ] sick right like I haven't tasted
his stuff but
there's a man who dedicated they speak
Japanese to by the way he speaks
Japanese he opened a ramen so Ivan
ramens this Jewish guy from the East
Coast who went to Japan fell in love
with the culture and he loved ramen so
much that he worked at a ramen shop paid
his dues as an apprentice built his own
ramen shop successful ramen shop too in
Japan in Japan he was covered in the
Japanese news and all that and people
started you know eating his ramen there
then he decided to come to the states
and build a shop and I was kind of
thinking about that and I'm like man
that's pretty interesting because here's
a guy who paid dues and he's dedicated
his life to ramen and then I'm
japanese-american and I haven't spent
the time that he did but if I open up a
ramen shop people will look at me and
say that's authentic versus him because
I'm Japanese right and I'm like but is
that really fair to that guy though cuz
he's paid a lot of dues and he's
actually lived in Japan longer than I
have
yeah and he studied under Japanese ramen
guys so who's gonna be more authentic I
don't even know yeah and you know when
you say that too about the fog I I could
really understand him maybe now that I
look back at it too and I agree with you
I did a whole video about it - why you
carried it funny though yeah I was like
I understand because it's just he
probably was speaking to other white
people to make sure that they don't [ __ ]
it up
yeah he was trying to do a service to
Asian people it just came off wrong it
came off like he knew everything or like
that's his [ __ ] yeah you know like I
don't know it's it's just man when it
comes to culture it's soul it is man you
got to be careful especially if you're
white and [ __ ] cuz it's not really that
guy that [ __ ] up it's just all the
people that's been [ __ ] up there's a
guy also - he's a joint called Pok Pok
and Pok Pok is his Thai place right this
[ __ ] goes to Thailand every
[ __ ] year yeah and he he speaks Thai
he's a white first of all dude Thai is a
very hard language in general and if for
a white guy to learn Thai and [ __ ] and
he eats like all the weird like real
[ __ ] big coagulated - yeah let's do it
that dude that feels like suck in a
period out of a pig's [ __ ] this was
eating some crazy
easy [ __ ] and then you know you'll read
some certain reviews like he's you know
why is this guy you know trying to
represent for Thai people he's not
making real authentic Thai food and was
like well he speaks Thai he goes every
[ __ ] year learns from chefs over
there you know pays due respect to the
culture make sure that it's authentic as
he could make it or what his versions of
it yeah say what more do you want for
the guy like [ __ ] like coat I think
cooking is is an art in and of itself
yeah you and it's kind of weird for
somebody to say to somebody else like
you can't do this because you don't look
like this to me that seed that's yeah
that's racist to like coming from our
side yeah saying like oh you're Mexican
you can't be cooking Asian food or you
don't know authentic Asian food I'm all
like I know a lot of Mexican chefs at
Chinese restaurants that could work some
real he they could work to walk like a
[ __ ] you know lay low mocha
classy ass [ __ ] dude Allison I'm
Sydney Australia and man so it was like
me Darion and and and and knowing we
were we did this seminar out there and
we had like probably one of the best
Thai foods outside of Thailand like it
was so [ __ ] good right and then we're
like man who's like who's the owner and
all that and then this white guy pops
out good I might literally write this
white guy comes out and we're like yo
man like compliments like this is
probably the best [ __ ] I've ever had
outside of like this is super real [ __ ]
yeah and he's like oh my god thank you
for saying that I appreciate it and he
was saying like you know if it's always
the Asians that tell me
it goes in and white people they I get
scolded by other white people no no [ __ ]
he's like he literally gets scolded by
white people that this isn't authentic
you know and he's like dude the cook
that's in the kitchen right now that
guy's on a work visa like any and he's
like he's like so he he bet he basically
has this work program that he rotates
from Thailand he I am him so his wife is
tied to so he goes out there and then
like every time they find like a dope
like street vendor or something they're
like oh my god this is so freaking good
you know and then they
they're like would you want to come to
America and then they'll come in I mean
uh Australia and then they'll work at
his restaurant and then teach his other
Thai cooks that are resident their trade
dude yeah and then they so every several
months they get new new cooks just
coming in teaching them different dishes
so it's as authentic or like yeah yeah
because it's fresh and it's like cooks
that have like they're just they you
know they were just in Thailand like a
month ago okay my mouth is watering
that's just yeah so all the stuff and
he's constantly trying to evolve and
figure out like new stuff so he's very
passionate his wife are both passionate
held there they live there like half of
the year because his wife's family is
out there yeah and um so but but the
funny thing is he was saying like what
people would stop him and and they think
he's like a worker there they don't
think that he owns up and then they'll
say like yeah you know this was terrible
this isn't authentic and like people
will complain to him like they're like
I've been at Island and it's not how
would you like Rio all the chefs and
they're just kind of so idk what's going
on you know that's so weird though
letting people who are so loud about
food sometimes you guys just don't know
[ __ ] so shut the [ __ ] up if you like
like that's the thing - if something
visually as well like David Chang right
when he was doing the whole ugly
delicious yeah it's like yo the [ __ ]
tastes [ __ ] good [ __ ] your perception
of what authenticity is yeah which is
something I really vibe with does it
taste good right that's yeah that's all
that matters yeah does it taste good and
you know we we could like I said we can
go and talk about you know paying
respect to cultures or whatever after
that but just initially what it is is
how I feel about film - right before you
go in and watch a film before you go
ahead and you dissect this film from top
to bottom about the lighting the
cinematography watch it did you like it
yes or no start with that first yeah and
then you can go ahead and dissect it
after because you're not even giving
something a chance mhm and that's what I
just [ __ ] hate sometimes I also think
people have expectations or like so like
picky people they have a specific thing
that they want right or they expect
something to happen so even if
something's actually good because
they're not open to it they go that's
not what that's not good because
that's not what I wanted mm-hmm so I get
it like if you bite into a [ __ ] mango
you're expecting a mango not like a
hamburger right so like yeah yeah yeah
so they might be surprised but at the
same time you gotta be more open with
food to enjoy food yeah I had like for
example like I've had Korean food my
whole life the way that my mom made it
right and if I just base it off the way
my mom made it and but and not thought
about how something tastes then I would
hate everybody else's Korean food right
but there are certain restaurants in
k-town that make certain foods better
than my mom knows Oh hands down yes
their specialty yeah and I eat it and
I'm like look at my mom I do hear that a
lot though people were like oh my mom
can make it better yeah like they say
that [ __ ] all day I'm like then [ __ ]
stay at home and eat all day doing it
yeah that's how it is like certain like
my mommy's really great side dishes and
I think she makes better than other
people because they don't season as well
but there are certain things that I've
eaten at restaurants that I would eat
their food over my mom's like for a fact
yeah you know cuz they're just better at
it than my mom is my mom knows she
doesn't better than mine you know is
better than mine and that's why she'll
go out and eat that instead of her own
[ __ ] so being open to these ideas about
food is very [ __ ] important yeah I
can't I can't really chill with picky
eaters man picky years are hard to enjoy
life with because food is like a big way
of bonding for me in experiencing life
yeah like traveling like if I travel
none of the people that I'm with can be
a picky eater yeah or they can't like
annoy the [ __ ] out of me yeah because I
like to try everything in anything
especially if I'm traveling so I think
I'm a little more picky when I'm back at
home yeah because I have my go-to places
and I'm like it's a routine out here
yeah but when I'm traveling I'm like why
don't you want to try everything like
you're gonna go to [ __ ] Costa Rica
and then like eat a hamburger at the
resort you know like I ain't gonna do
that exact no like imma imma eat
whatever they got there yeah and food
food is like man I'm telling you just
like having to level up with it's very
important because you know just to go
and this was actually supposed to be the
topic which is really quite safe we've
basically not they don't want
people just don't leave their [ __ ]
names as anonymous but they were talking
about what it takes to have a very
successful food or a restaurant oh [ __ ]
you know which kind of bleeds into this
topic either way which is great but that
that's such a loaded question because
there's so many moving parts to it right
because it's a it's a huge figuring out
process and we're still figuring it out
as we go yeah and I think everyone has
to define what success is to them okay
cuz we did we did a good job of
establishing that with our group because
we were like what do you want to make do
you want to make a chain that like blows
up and it's in it's in every single
corner like Starbucks do you wanna have
a boutique shop that's like very high
quality and like it's only one location
but the world knows about it like
everyone has to define what success is
to them specifically because not
everyone's gonna think the same you know
yeah yeah our food business is to what I
look what I like about it I think more
than anything else it's I mean if you
want to boil it down aside from just
food it's just to find the right people
we don't we take critique very seriously
in the sense of seriously in the sense
of what you say matters but not serious
enough where hurts our feelings yeah
that's very important I think it's it's
super important to listen to it depends
on what you make right yeah so if if
food to you is an art form right like as
in the sense of you taken so seriously
to the point where you eat live and
breathe it as if it's like a personal
extension of your spirit and body then a
lot of the times
public perception of your food if you
think it's good it's a [ __ ] you it's
hurtful yeah yeah so there's a lot of
like top chefs yeah who had the palate
for it and they had that attitude and
the restaurants do well because of the
the level of culinary expertise that
they have their palate the foods that
they've eaten what they developed yeah
that makes sense we are not that we do
not have that and I know that about
myself we just know that what we like
and then we put it out and then we make
adjustments to see what's that perfect
medium of what I can offer and then what
you guys want
I call it folksy food yeah it's you know
it's just every day
dude it's not it's not pretentious it's
not super you know it's like good
quality food to enjoy and have fun with
yeah because I like making statements
with foods to it to a certain extent
right yeah so when we you know for
example with like that we had this
chicken wing spot called wing chicks
right soft-launched right now and then
we're working on it and we're expanding
so joe and i worked on the original
recipe and we're not so like dogmatic on
the approach where when we gave it to
our team to develop it we you know they
you know they even asked like do you
mind if we three guys i don't give a
[ __ ] yeah do whatever yeah do what you
have to do like this is what i like i
think a lot of people they can't get
past this part and they get into fights
and then they break up I've seen so many
businesses fail because of the egos
about the emotions and then the
stubbornness and I and I think that's
like probably one of the biggest things
it's like can you make a dish and not
get your feelings hurt when someone says
it kind of sucks yeah or not even it
kind of sucks you know like it's not for
them or it's too spicy or it's this or
it's that and you got a survey a lot of
people because that's the only way
you're gonna get better but also take it
with a grain of salt because it's a
balancing act right that person might
not like spicy things because that
person just doesn't like spicy periods
so that information might not be the
best for you yeah someone else might
like be like I want it more salty but
this person is a smoker and a drinker
and their [ __ ] taste buds are shot
you know so like you have to take into
consideration each individual and the
more you listen I think the better you
get instead of immediately trying to
come up with the answer oh the reason
why there's salt is because of this it's
like you can't reason with people what
they like or don't like that's the thing
is people need to shut the [ __ ] up let
them taste and then just listen to what
they got to say and that's the truth
with all business right like it could be
anything like its its it could be like
hey what do you think of my [ __ ]
camera that I designed you know and then
they'll be like well I don't really like
how this lens is like this most
designers will say oh that's because no
try to [ __ ] defend it
just shut the [ __ ] up and listen and be
like okay take the damn note and really
make sure that that's what it is if
you're feeling something about it then
you're not ready to be in business
that's my opinion
yeah and if it's on on the other end of
like you that's how you like it that you
also have to understand what that
entails
yeah cool I like it this way I'm gonna
sell it and if you're okay with losing
out on customers who don't like it that
way but there's a fat amount that who do
like it that way true then stick with
those people stick stick to what you
know yeah you know for example we also
have a match of business right we have
to brick and mortars for it we also have
a floating business that goes to
different different venues and stuff
like that and we're continuing to expand
that for us too as somebody who does
matcha we have to figure out for
ourselves number one who is our target
demographic who are we trying to bring
this to who are we trying to make this
accessible to because it's a very easy
thing for us to go like okay only a
certain amount of people like matcha
let's put on thirty coffee drinks yep
because this is just so I don't lose the
the coffee customer and what I call that
it's something very simple I always
called it it's like don't try to be the
Chinese sushi ramen shop the Chinese who
she ramen I mean cuz you'll see that in
LA where's a business there's so many
different foods that they don't want to
lose all these different customers so
they do three things very mediocre just
so they could try to please everybody
yeah and those restaurants I kid you
[ __ ] not unless it's like a
late-night place that's been open for a
long time and as a statement always you
know they [ __ ] fail always always a
hundred percent because their food has
to be craveable and memorable is what I
say when somebody let me think about
your favorite restaurants right when you
go into your favorite restaurant how
many times do you ever deviate from the
normal things that you actually buy you
just go to that staple thing exactly
yeah it's your statement piece right I
go to this place called a hundy buck in
k-town right new I like that spot they
have them they have a [ __ ] huge menu
yeah a lot of different Korean stews all
this other side dish they even have like
like their Korean barbecue there I've
gone there now for ten years I haven't
ordered anything but two dishes there
they're kinda Tong which is their their
potato pork necks do yeah and they're
pork ribs that's I always get that -
same thing every time without fail
haven't gotten it sometimes I get the
pork belly the cold pork belly though oh
yeah that's good yeah there's all this
other yeah there's another Korean
restaurant that I always go to it's
called a Humvee pocketbook Obama about
Koba does so this thing called opossum
which is a soy braised pork belly that
you have pickled different pickled
vegetables with and wraps and I ordered
that and they're hemorrhaging which is a
seafood pancake I ordered those two
things every [ __ ] time even though
their menus like visually things and
they make a lot of great food yeah but I
don't need to order anything else and
that's how most people order yeah I
think so yeah
yeah even when you go to a far
restaurant right there's like 20
different Fuzz you could probably get
but people were like I want the the Fudd
act bit yeah what a fun tie yeah give me
that same [ __ ] every time so most of my
friends order the same way - they don't
I don't know many people that would like
order different things maybe like Josh
he would look at the menu and he'll go
that one ass cuz that feels like trying
new [ __ ] every time that's basically
what it feels different it's a little
sandy he's like that's I mean there's a
few people who do that I'm not saying
that when you open up these restaurants
you shouldn't have a menu - - to have
people try different things yeah but
understand that when you make your menu
too big and it's not focused that's true
that's when [ __ ] starts to [ __ ] up a lot
yeah I think focus is the key right so
like to do anything successful is like
first you got to define what success is
to you because what's successful to me
isn't you know gonna be the same for you
and that is like going back to the whole
focus thing is you have to you have to
know what you want and what you're
trying to achieve instead of starting
something and hoping that it works right
so when you when you know like okay what
is successful to me is I want to be a
superstar sushi chef like jiro Dreams of
Sushi or whatever you know like and it's
gonna be a very small place and I'm only
gonna serve ten customers but I'm gonna
you know have a menu that's like a
thousand bucks per customer and that's
how I'm gonna survive or you could be
like you know what I just want to
Faye that's open for breakfast and so
first you want to define that and be
like I want to and what is your what is
your like epitome of success like I want
to be in on every street corner in every
major city all over the world or like I
want three locations or you just want
one place one little diner that you're
open for lunch and then you have all
this extra time to do whatever the hell
you want so I would say define that
first and foremost because all of it is
achievable yeah it just it just it's
it's it makes it less achievable when
you don't have that focus and I think a
lot of people fail because they're like
running around trying to define when the
success isn't defined the running around
trying to catch what they think is
successful at the moment so they go back
to doing like well we can't not serve
coffee because what about all the coffee
drinkers that are gonna come here or
like they're afraid now so you're not
being bold they're being afraid of like
well we might lose business so we can't
do this and we can't do that yeah so
yeah that's a really good tip because I
think it's like I've had different
business partners before and that was
something that I've always tried to
express and communicate with you know
with with I've had like one that's not
failed but that was the biggest downfall
of the business is that number one these
partners couldn't take critique very
well from customers they thought that
every customer when they had a critique
they were dumped which was not true they
had a lot of great things to say you
know if a customer comes in right and
that's the hard part when you're on Yelp
and you're reading all these comments
when a customer says like hey the the
soft serve was you know it was a little
icy today right you could say in your
mind they don't know what good soft
serve is or if there's two comments like
that you can go and check the machine to
see if it is right there's there's a
certain level of like understanding when
something's [ __ ] or sometimes where
you have to stand your ground or you
Orr's critique that you should really
learn from yeah like for example if we
have a matcha place right and there's a
girl named Betty MIT beckerson and she
goes this is an authentic matcha from
Japan she can go [ __ ] herself yeah right
because we've been to that farm we saw
the the 3000 year old Japanese ladies
individually
believe themselves we saw the stone mill
that grinds our matcha yeah from our
very specific place as that's as
authentic as it [ __ ] get yeah that
person who writes that comment I'm not
gonna tell them [ __ ] you but in my mind
I'm not gonna change my business or the
things that I'm doing yeah because of
that comment that's different mm-hmm but
if somebody comes in and they go hey
when I got my matcha it was really
gritty and there was something wrong
with it I might check it I'm like yeah
it might be one of the workers that's
adding a little too much powder yeah you
don't know yeah but it is good to take
in critique yeah I mean there's just so
much more to it but I think first and
foremost you got to define your dream
and success and what you want and just
go toward that direction and I think so
much so many people don't take the time
to do that and looking back if I were
able to do that again with all of my
businesses I think that would be a lot
better for everything yeah for us and
our restaurant stuff I think we did have
a goal at one point and it was to just
open up a few local places and I think
we didn't realize how successful things
can be and I didn't understand the scale
of this world oh yeah so once we
realized how big this was gonna be like
we have a we actually have a lot of
wealthy fans who want to invest and who
want to buy franchises who wants to open
up a spot in their area in their country
and when this opened up it just
basically changed the whole game because
I was like you know probably you know
build this business with a bunch of my
friends and open up five stores for each
concept or whatever in LA and call it a
day mm-hmm but when that change like
that that idea really made my mind go oh
[ __ ]
like we could turn this into a global
thing yeah so why not let's go for it
and then everyone was like yeah dude
like well the top people were like we
don't need this for money what we want
to do is make a mark right so let's
freaking go big and in so it changed the
whole idea of what was successful in our
dream so and it could I think I could
constantly change too but once it
changes then
how you approach it has to change as
well and if you're doing this by
yourself or if you have partners I think
defining defining jobs and strengths are
it's very important because you don't
want to step on people's toes and you
also have to understand when people own
equity in your company and depending on
their business it's like you have to
really clearly define what they do how
good they are at doing it and if you
trust them to do it in the [ __ ] first
place oh yeah
so a lot of this time when you kind of
go the reason why people say this like
don't go into business with friends it's
not because the the friendship part is
[ __ ] up what's [ __ ] up is
expectations of what you expect out of
your friends without clearly defining it
before you start and you start to see
shitty parts of your friends yes like
you don't realize how lazy some of your
friends are until you start working with
them
yeah or how selfish or how you know
there's just [ __ ] that comes out and
you've got to be prepared for it well
what I love about business and what I
love about all these things though is it
either builds stronger friendships or it
may it builds strong friendships and it
builds strong character yeah so like
yeah it sucks you might lose some
friends you might go through all this
stuff but you come out stronger you come
out better it's just overall I feel like
everyone should open up a business cuz
this is how the country used to be right
like it used to be ran by small
businesses family farms all that [ __ ]
and I just think it just builds so much
yeah good personality traits I've
definitely learned a lot I mean if you
guys want like I told this personal
story when we first started this podcast
like episode like 5 or 6 but yeah I had
a business partner that [ __ ] me over
like he [ __ ] didn't do any work faked
a seizure did all his other [ __ ]
just to get out of [ __ ] work when Tec
came back with like sunglasses and
shades with dirts on his face and [ __ ]
oh you know when you left the [ __ ]
store open to these people who don't
even know how to run it started using a
company credit card to fund his private
dinners didn't did a lot of uh what a
lot of like shady [ __ ] [ __ ] right and
let me fake a seizure so I get out of a
meeting yeah exactly you [ __ ] loser I
hope you're dead anyways but you know
with him and that was my fault too like
I I trusted his skills and the ability
as a chef but I should have really
tested his business IQ right I didn't
really think about that
[ __ ] because I said you can make great
food like I love his food it's great
it's the problem with that is that's
just because you could make great food
doesn't mean you're a great business
owner it doesn't translate that no and I
didn't think about that [ __ ] I've done
this a couple [ __ ] times
boys I always [ __ ] this up because I
believe in people a lot of you [ __ ] me
in the ass now I've got so much better
but Joe knows and so you know this guy
he even had two suits like I like
there's something small right and there
was this other partner too but this
person always took things personally so
they wanted to experiment and put things
on the menu right and there's a few
things I'd put on the menu that did
really [ __ ] well it was killing it
yeah and I think is I think I understand
people very well I understand like this
flavor profile very well and it does
well so they wanted to step up to the
place of all I can make good stuff to
and I'm like oh cool like go ahead so
they put up their menu it sold like two
in like a week and what they were pissed
yeah it's like well who are you mad at
right now yeah are you mad at me
yes I'm not laughing at you because what
I said was I was like hey like let's
take this off the menu it's not working
right and they're like well I like it I
don't give a [ __ ] if you like it it's
not selling we just wasted a [ __ ] kind
of money oh it's not a personal thing
right and and I when I was talking to
them I gave them an example I was like
well I I put a secret menu item on right
yeah and I was a little pissed because
when I asked it to be done it wasn't
done and they put it on there two months
later past the season that it should
have been out oh and so they're like
well it's not doing well I was like no
[ __ ] like you didn't do it when I asked
you to do it we were promoting you so it
was promoted but the item wasn't there
example was showing up where's the
secret item they're like it's not it's
not there so duh it's not being sold
exactly lo and behold is because that
person didn't want to put it up because
it wasn't his idea
so he lagged and lagged on us I see it
didn't do well it's like yet because
sabotage there's sabotage the marketing
plan wasn't executed for it
see that's what I mean by like ego and
pettiness and stubbornness I've seen
businesses hurt by that more than
anything terrible yeah it's because like
like think about it this guy's pride was
hurt so bad that he sabotaged her
business making money and I've seen that
a lot it's not
just in your situation I've experienced
it I think a lot of people out there and
that's what discourages a lot of people
from going forward but then it what it
ends up doing is like now you can see it
from a mile away if a [ __ ] comes
around and they have that kind of vibe
about them I think you'll be able to
pick it out and go oh you remind me of
this guy I'm not gonna [ __ ] around with
you yeah it only took me thirty years
doing enough I finally got like a sense
that [ __ ] goddamn it man it's just I
believe in a lot of people's talent but
then I'm now I'm understanding that
talent only means [ __ ] to a certain
extent there and when it comes to a
business honesty loyalty yeah and uh
like dedication and understanding work
is way better than somebody who's
talented cuz we could find a talent and
they don't be a part of the biz no you
can hire them yes um you know it's like
the artists curse you know all they care
about is the thing yeah whatever they're
creating but also there's a lot of great
artists out there that can work with
people I just think like it's one of
those things about like you just gotta
go through sometimes it's like dating
right you got to go through a lot of
shitty people sometimes to know what you
want and who's good who's trustworthy
yeah
it's the same thing with business and
working with others usually like in a
company you know the HR and the hiring
they're doing the filtering for you so
when you're working with people like if
someone [ __ ] up hopefully the manager
or whoever is dealing with them properly
disciplining them or whatever and
kicking out people and so you don't
really have to deal with that [ __ ] yeah
but when you're out there in the world
by yourself it's pretty hard because you
have to pick and choose and gamble with
people that's why going into business
where you really respect the other
person is very important because I also
know a personal friend of mine where
they've so they own a restaurant and you
know the business did really well but
what happened was because they had a
disagreement on food items and what the
way certain things were run specifically
one of these partners decided to go off
and do their own thing right so they
went off and did their own thing but the
problem with that was
cool you make great food but a
restaurant isn't just food it's an
analysis it's a functioning living thing
right and so this human being
underestimated what the other partners
did and thought that hey I know food I
can do this without you guys I don't
need you lo and behold opens up their
own restaurant [ __ ] tanks you know
why because he forgot that number one
your other two partners we're dealing
with staffing training staff cleaning
doing the system branding logos menus
all this other stuff that you really
thought that number one was the easiest
thing in the world because you didn't
respect your partner's you found out how
much they contributed when you try to
open your own can you fail and you're
like and yeah and you're like [ __ ] I
can't go back to them that is factly
you're [ __ ] you know that's what I'm
saying like respect what people do and
understand their job positions and
understand that they do it well or not
yeah but that that's also another thing
too is like never completely burning a
bridge because if if your friend was
like I'm not sure if I could do this on
my own but let me let me talk to the
guys and go hey guys like this this this
thing maybe it's not efficient what do
you think about me going off on my own
and then like you know we figure out a
situation here where like I don't want
to fight with you guys anymore
right now and then so he gets their
blessing opens up a different place
maybe they'll share half of each or
whatever he could experiment on his own
running his own place but have enough
where he can go back without his tail
tucked between his [ __ ] legs you know
and he can go back and and and really
now respect them and be like all [ __ ]
you know like I do need you guys yeah
it's just that it's that problem of
disagreeing with somebody without
getting your [ __ ] feelings hurt man I
think it's always about I think the core
is is all always about negotiation right
to make to be a great business person I
think it's it's really that like I'm
always figuring out a situation where
you can you can kind of have a lot of
options and come out clean and win for
everyone yeah because if you guys want a
specific
example it's like even with some of the
restaurants that we have if I ran it the
way I wanted to doesn't mean that the
way the way I do it is right it's just a
preference yeah it's like I would take
these things off the menu right but if
seven of the partners like no we like it
and it's doing well yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] about my opinion my opinion doesn't
matter it's irrelevant it's irrelevant
right it's just how I personally would
do it but it doesn't my personal
feelings about something that isn't
doing the business any good doesn't
[ __ ] matter it doesn't and doesn't
matter and good is to me is profit
mm-hmm it's profitable yeah people like
it people like it now it's just a
preference mm-hmm and being able to tell
myself like yo man [ __ ] your opinion
tell yourself that yeah sometimes like
your opinion doesn't matter David
because doing well so what are you
saying yeah it's true then tell my son
like oh that's true like it doesn't
really matter right and if if I'm trying
to like I said if there's these
businesses were my pride and joy in that
sense of it was my art piece it'd be
different right cuz I would do
everything by myself
but it's not it's something that I want
I want to make accessible food for
people to enjoy and that's what it's
doing yeah and that's what I get out of
it and that's all that's what's
successful to you right yep cuz like you
have to define that or else you get too
caught up in everything and you don't
know what to react to mmhmm yeah exactly
well I hope that answers your business
questions if you guys are trying to open
up a restaurant number one a lot of
restaurants do fail specifically in this
city
yeah I think one out of ten make it
first to pass five years yeah and after
that it's it's a free-for-all man
because I've seen a lot of great
restaurants in LA but I used to go to if
the food was good but they just up and
disappeared mm-hm so getting into a
restaurants very hard be very smart be
very calculated and then yeah it's tough
it's a tough world out there guys and
we're still learning too yeah so who
knows well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast
where we talked about everything food
culinary whitewashing of [ __ ] and how to
open up your own food business and you
guys can catch us on any of those audio
platforms if you see us on iTunes
specifically give us that five star
let's get that visibility out there if
you're seeing this on YouTube leave some
comments below
about what you guys think have
discussions have conversations and let
us know what you guys want us to talk
about next we will see you all next time
goodbye pace